[Music]
wait wait wait hold
on you okay yeah great okay I'll be
right back
get see his
[Music]
underwear Tom are you okay do I know you
man no but I've been watching over you
your whole life who are
you
[Music]
wa I know it's cool your grandmother was
a guardian sworn to protect
Humanity now the duty of protecting it
is yours very funny right it's time to
start your training oh it's
on whoa okay hold on no no no no
[Music]
no wait how did you know I was going to
survive I didn't is that a
dragon show off it will be my honor to
guide you wait we're getting him some
not everything is what it seems
[Music]
kid
zodiac sworn to protect the guardian
who's the featherweight hi I'm Tom
lactose intolerant and guardian of a
Steph Curry rookie card
what feel the power inside you oh
yeah
[Music]
wait you don't talk too do you about to
be
on we need you for what's
coming who said kids can't fly I hope
you ain't afraid this I don't know if I
can be who you need me to be your
grandma believed in you it's in your
blood I've waited a thousand years for
this
moment I am the guardian we've got this
zodiac up oh
yeah you know that it's coming
yeah know that is
[Music]
coming
he